sont désormais mises en oeuvre dans
trois départements supplémentaires vous
le savez la situation est encore plus
dégradée la pression épidémie qui
atteint des niveaux alarmants la
pression sanitaires se fait fortement
sentir sur les hôpitaux et la médecine
de ville et la dynamique épidémie qui
est forte
il s'agit de la nièvre du rhône et de
l'aube pour ces trois départements
après concertation avec les élus mais
aussi avec les services de l'état avec
les établissements de santé
il est apparu indispensable d'amplifier
les mesures de protection
à l'instar de ce qui a été mise en
oeuvre la semaine dernière dans les
départements concernés en ile-de-france
dans les hauts de france et en normandie
à compter de ce vendredi minuit et pour
quatre semaines donc dans ces trois
départements le couvre-feu continue de
s'appliquer
de 19 heures à 6 heures les
rassemblements en extérieur ne doivent
pas dépasser six personnes les
déplacements sont autorisés de 6 heures
à 19 heures lorsque c'est dans un rayon
inférieur à 10 km sans attestation sans
limitation de durée
on vous demande d'avoir sur vous un
justificatif de domicile comme une pièce
d'identité entre 6 heures et 19 heures
si vous dépassez 10 km depuis votre
domicile mais également de 19h à 6h
cette fois ci quelle que soit la
distance vous devrez avoir une
attestation dérogatoire les déplacements
inter régionaux sont interdits sauf
motif impérieux ou professionnels les
commerces de première nécessité reste
ouvert les écoles maternelles et
primaires et les collèges restent
ouverts tandis que les lycées passe tout
son demi jauge enfin les lieux de culte
restent ouverts ce sont donc dans ces
trois départements les mêmes mesures de
freinage fortes qui sont mises en place
que celle annoncée dans les autres
départements concernés la semaine
dernière face à l'ampleur de la vague à
sa diffusion sur une partie croissante
du territoire
certaines voix se font entendre qu'ils
demandent le retour un confinement plus
dur allant jusqu'à la fermeture des
écoles
je voudrais vous rappeler sur quels
éléments nous fondons nos décisions
pourquoi des mesures à l'échelle des
départements des régions plutôt qu'une
mesure unique au niveau national d'abord
le virus ne circule pas partout de la
même manière
et avec la même intensité par exemple le
finistère est dix fois moins touchée que
la seine-saint-denis
nous mesurons par ailleurs le niveau de
contrainte qui sont imposés aux français
et nous les ajustons aux enjeux propres
à chaque territoire tout en tenant
compte de l'acceptabilité après plus
d'un an de lutte collective contre le
virus
lorsqu'un département nous inquiète en
particulier
nous consultons les élus et nous
adoptons avait que des mesures
proportionnées pour freiner l'épidémie
pourquoi est ce que nous vous
recommandons de ne pas vous réunir à
plus de six personnes
nous savons qu'il faut limiter le
contact sociaux tout simplement parce
que le virus se transmet d'une personne
à une autre
plus vous êtes nombreux à vous retrouver
surtout dans des espaces clos et encore
plus lorsque vous ne portait pas de
masque plus le virus trouvera une
personne a contaminé par milou pourquoi
même à l'extérieur nous vous invitons à
ne pas être plus de 6 tout simplement
parce que même si être dehors affaibli
le risque si vous vous retrouvez à 15
comme sur les quais par exemple en train
de partager un moment de convivialité
vous allez immanquablement un moment
donné baisser la garde
réduire les distances baisser le masque
et pourquoi pas même d'ailleurs trinquer
bref vous allez de fait augmenter le
risque de vous infecter
pourquoi ce que nous incitons très
fortement les entreprises à privilégier
le télétravail pour limiter les
déplacements et les risques de
transmission sur le lieu de travail
le télétravail est possible dans bien
des cas et dans bien des cas les
entreprises qui le peuvent le mettre en
oeuvre
je sais que les entreprises sont
vigilantes je sais que depuis un an nous
avons fait des pas de géant avec les
visio avec les réunions en ligne au
ministère je ne fait d'ailleurs pas
autre chose avec les médecins des
réanimations les infirmiers les acteurs
du monde de la santé et des solidarités
pourquoi le couvre feu le couvre-feu
c'est une mesure destinée à éviter les
rassemblements nocturnes les soirées les
dîners les uns chez les autres tout ce
qui nous manque un mois le premier
d'ailleurs depuis un an maintenant
mais être à dix dans un salon être à dix
autour d'une table quelles que soient
les précautions
c'est un terrain propice à la diffusion
du virus le lendemain un invité peut
avoir des symptômes
puis un deuxième je vous épargne la
suite
pourquoi est-ce que nous maintenons les
écoles ouvertes
la fermeture des écoles c'est une
décision de dernier recours que nous
voulons à tout prix éviter parce que
nous savons qu'elle a des conséquences
très lourdes sur le développement des
enfants et sur le quotidien des parents
nous ne nions pas que le virus peut
aussi se transmettre à l'école puis de
l'école vers les familles c'est pourquoi
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer
nous travaillerons à des protocoles
sanitaires renforcés en sus de ceux qui
sont déjà mises en place dans les
établissements scolaires toute la
communauté éducative veille à ce que la
vie dans les écoles les collèges et les
lycées puisse continuer en limitant au
maximum les risques de transmission nous
organisons aussi vous le savez des
campagnes de dépistage collectif avec
les tests salivaires et lorsqu'il le
faut nous fermons des classes hier 2962
classes étaient fermés et 105 écoles
nelson mandela a disait que l'éducation
est lé arme la plus puissante que l'on
peut utiliser pour changer le monde il y
aura un après qu'ovide bientôt et être
parvenu à maintenir les écoles ouvertes
sera une force pour la jeune génération
nous ne fermons n'avons fermé une
fermerions les écoles quand dernière
nécessité pourquoi ne pas confiné
puisque l'épidémie s'aggrave
malgré les mesures décidées la semaine
dernière un confinement généralisée
d'abord vous le savez c'est un niveau de
contrainte extrême pour des français
épuisés de lutter sans relâche depuis un
an
un coup d'arrêt pour notre économie une
réduction forte des mobilités dans notre
quotidien qui ont d'ailleurs aussi des
conséquences plus complexe certes à elle
a évalué dans l'immédiateté qu'une
courbe d'hospitalisation est pourtant
bien réelle c'est une décision qui ne se
prend que lorsque toutes les autres
options n'ont pas suffi à endiguer
l'épidémie
surtout il est trop tôt trop tôt pour
juger si les mesures sont efficaces et
suffisamment efficace une personne
diagnostiquée aujourd'hui a été
contaminé il y a trois ou quatre jours
par quelqu'un qui lui-même a été
contaminé plusieurs jours auparavant les
mesures décidées la semaine dernière
pourrait montrer leurs premiers effets
nous le souhaitons d'ici sodifis ce week
end au mieux en début de semaine
prochaine sans doute d'ailleurs comme
pour les deux premières vagues
souvenez-vous il a fallu une grue
semaines pour que l'incidence commence à
baisser après la mise en place du
confinement et plus de deux semaines
pour qu'on en mesure l'impact sur les
hospitalisations et les réanimations
cela signifie que dans les prochains
jours la pression sanitaire la pression
hospitalière déjà forte va continuer de
monter cette pression sanitaire je
voudrais l'illustré devant vous avec la
situation en ile-de-france la pression
sur l'hôpital y atteint à nouveau des
niveaux critiques que ce soit en
réanimation mais aussi désormais en
hospitalisation conventionnel à l'heure
où nous parlons 1410 patients
réanimatoires touché par le cos vides
sont accueillis dans les hôpitaux
franciliens ce sont au total près de
sept mille malades ducobu qui sont
hospitalisés comme beaucoup de
réanimateurs en témoigne et comme
désormais les chiffres l'attestent
également le profil de ces patients
change plus jeunes et parfois sans
aucune comorbidités cette situation est
la conséquence directe et j'allais dire
implacable de la puissance de l'épidémie
qui a cours dans notre capitale face à
cette situation au début de la semaine
le système de santé francilien s'est
engagée vers ce qu'on appelle le pilier
le palier 4 de la montée en puissance de
la capacité hospitalière
au delà de 1500 lits chiffre qui sera
atteint dans les tout prochains jours
vous le voyez il faut en effet que les
hôpitaux publics et privés franciliens
armes 2250 lits de réanimation
juste pour les malades qu'ovide on manie
beaucoup de chiffres dans cette épidémie
parfois certains des défis auxquels le
système de santé est confronté sont
comme banalisée dans la mobilisation au
cours de la dernière année a permis de
réaliser des choses que l'on pensait
collectivement inatteignable et je veux
le dire ouvrir deux mille deux cents
lits de réanimation pour des patients
qu'aux vide en ile de france c'est un
défi immense immense autant que le sont
les puisement et l' angoisse des
soignants qui doit faire face à cette
troisième vague il ya la fatigue
évidemment il est la peur à laquelle je
faisais référence à l'instant il y à
aussi au quotidien les choix que cette
situation impose aujourd'hui ce sont
entre 35 et 40% des activités
et programme est qu'ils ont été reportés
à terme si on veut rendre disponibles
les deux mille deux cent cinquante lits
de réanimation se sont sans doute 80% de
ses activités qui devrait être
déprogrammé au quotidien pour les
soignants mais évidemment aussi pour les
patients et leurs familles cette
situation est très difficile à vivre
ces choix sont toujours fait dans la
collégialité aucun d'eux n'est simple
c'est pourquoi freiner l'épidémie
ce n'est pas seulement prendre soins de
l'hôpital c'est prendre soin l'hôpital
bien sûr des soignants mais c'est aussi
et sans doute d'abord des malades qui
risquent de voir leurs interventions
reporter je mesure parce que je suis moi
même un soignant ce que sont ces heures
dans lesquels des choix médicaux et donc
des choix éthiques doivent être faits
aux côtés des soignants toutes les
équipes du ministère des solidarités et
de la santé que ce soit l'échelon
national ou dans les agences régionales
de santé
toutes les équipes sont mobilisées pour
accompagner cette montée en puissance et
lever tous les obstacles qui doivent
être levés nous relançons la
mobilisation de renforts
nous facilitons autant que possible
l'ouverture exceptionnelle d' unité de
réanimation le dialogue entre les
hôpitaux publics et les hôpitaux privés
est aujourd'hui d'une fluidité qui n'a
sans doute jamais connu auparavant
aucune force aucune ressource n'est
compromise par des jeux de rôle ou de
l'attentisme
je m'assure au quotidien que cette
mobilisation est collective et je sais
aujourd'hui qu'elle est totalement je le
disais nous constatons un certain
rajeunissement des malades admis en
réanimation
quelles en sont les raisons avec la
campagne vaccinale qui protège
graduellement et prioritairement les
plus vulnérables de nos concitoyens le
profil des personnes qui arrivent en
réanimation a changé et nous constatons
est relatif rajeunissement de ces
personnes en comparaison des données
observées en novembre et en décembre
2020 mais nous observons également une
tendance à l'augmentation du risque
d'être admis en réanimation quand on est
malade
entre 15 et 75 ans à partir du mois de
février dernier et une légère
augmentation de la sévérité de la
maladie chez l'adulte en particulier
l'adulte jeune
lié à la diffusion est liée aux
caractéristiques des variants c'est
pourquoi j'insiste parce qu'il n'est pas
rare que j'entende que les jeunes ne
craignent rien certes les jeunes
craignent moins mais ils ne sont pas à
l'abri je ne parle pas des nombreux
français de tous âges qui présente des
semaines après une maladie à qu'ovide
sans gravité particulière des symptômes
persistants tels que perte du goût et de
l'odorat céphalées douleurs articulaires
fatigué mesdames messieurs
même si le temps et est source
d'agacement d'impatience et d'une
lassitude que je comprends le temps joue
en notre faveur
il nous rend plus fort il nous rend
mieux armés face à l'épidémie
nous prévenons mieux nous vaccinons
mieux et nous soignons mieux mon souhait
c'est qu'au delà de cette lassitude nous
restions collectivement et
individuellement mobilisés pour nous
protéger et protéger celles et ceux qui
sont susceptibles de développer des
formes graves de la maladie et vous le
savez chacun de vos gestes au quotidien
peut compter zone alimenterait pas ici
le débat sémantique sur la justesse sur
la pertinence du mot confinement chacun
a pu constater que les mesures décidées
était différente de celle décidée il ya
un an
on entend souvent je ne sais pas si
c'est une légende que les inuits ou
plusieurs dizaines de mots pour désigner
le mot neige
la langue française est riche elle est
très riche mais elles manquent de mots
pour qualifier cette situation si
particulière qu'est la mise entre
parenthèses d'un certain nombre de nos
libertés et la mise en suspens de notre
mode de vie
ce que je veux dire ici que ce qu'il n'y
a pas un confinement
il y a passez moi l'expression 50 nuance
de mesures qui tiennent compte de la
situation épidémique proprement dit et
de ce que nous savons du virus depuis un
an je dis que cette épidémie
elle est évolutive elle est évolutive
parce que le virus ne circule pas
toujours à la même vitesse
elle est évolutive parce que des
variantes sont apparus elle est
évolutive parce que les connaissances
d'hier ne sont pas celles d'aujourd'hui
et que les connaissances d'aujourd'hui
ne sont pas celles de demain
elle est évolutive parce que la
vaccination change la donne le choix
qu'a fait le gouvernement c'est le choix
de la confiance parce que malgré la
fatigue malgré la lassitude le
découragement et parfois la colère
chacun comprend que les décisions ne
sont pas prises par fantasy les
décisions sont prises à partir de ce que
nous avons appris et nous avons beaucoup
appris c'est bien la moindre des choses
me direz vous mais quand un événement
aussi inattendu surgi face à un virus
inconnu ou mal connus le manque de
connaissances théoriques et pratiques
est un handicap considérable que l'on ne
peut surmonter khaled de l'expérience et
du temps nous avons appris par exemple à
mieux détecter la maladie
proposer des dispositifs de dépistage
systématique des malades sur tout le
territoire
c'est une prouesse technique et
logistique dont la france a été et reste
capable aujourd'hui dans nos villes dans
nos campagnes nos concitoyens peuvent se
faire tester gratuitement pour se
protéger et protéger leurs proches cette
semaine ce sont plus de 2 8 millions de
tests qui ont ainsi été réalisées nous
avons également appris à mieux soigner
mieux prendre en charge les patients à
l'hôpital comme en ville grâce à la
mobilisation de la médecine de ville et
de l'hospitalisation à domicile des
patients sont soignés chez eux y compris
avec de l'oxygène
aujourd'hui à l'hôpital délits sont
déployés avec un nombre de lits de soins
critiques de réanimation bien plus
important qu'avant la crise et qui sont
capables de s'adapter aux évolutions de
l'épidémie et aux besoins de chaque
territoire
aujourd'hui nous savons organiser des
transferts sanitaire par voie terrestre
ou aérienne qui permettent de répartir
la charge entre les services de
réanimation de tout le territoire
36 évacuations sanitaires ont été
réalisés au cours de la semaine
précédente
au départ des hauts de france de
provence alpes côte d'azur et de l'île
de france
nous réaliserons au moins le même volume
cette semaine et nous accélérons à
chaque fois
breysse ans nous réalisons l'espoir nous
vaccinons tous les jours de la semaine
en flux tendu avec toutes les doses dont
nous disposons et nous allons encore
augmenter ce rythme quotidien nous
dépasseront bientôt les 400000
injections par jour puis les 500000
injections par jour et ainsi de suite
si l'on fait le bilan nous avons dépassé
ce soir pardon le graf n'est pas
complètement à jour nous n'avons pas
intégré les données d'aujourd'hui mais
nous avons dépassé les 7 millions de
personnes en france qui ont été vaccinés
parmi ces 7 millions personnes plus de
2.5 ont reçu leur deuxième injection ils
sont donc totalement protégé plus de la
moitié des personnes de plus de 75 ans
vivant dans notre pays ont reçu au moins
une injection et plus de 90% dans les
ehpad
c'est pourquoi nous nous avons fait le
choix de passer à la classe d'âge
suivantes par ordre de priorité cet
ordre de priorité c'est l'ordre de
risques devant le virus à compter de
samedi
la vaccination sera ouverte à toutes les
personnes de plus de 70 ans qui auront
le choix de se rendre ou en centres de
vaccination ou chez leur médecin
traitant ou dans leur pharmacie
je m'adresse un instant aux personnes de
plus de 75 ans qui n'auraient pas encore
pris rendez-vous ainsi qu'à leurs
proches et qui parfois sont encore en
difficulté pour avoir un rendez vous
même si nous ouvrons la vaccination à
davantage de nos concitoyens notre
objectif est de continuer à vous aider à
vous accompagner pour vous faire
vacciner
nous n'abandonnerons personnes les
collectivités locales les professionnels
les associations font déjà un gros
travail pour vous contacter et vous
proposer des rendez vous pour aller plus
loin comme l'a annoncé le président de
la république nous allons déployer une
campagne d'appels téléphoniques
systématique qui seront assurés par
l'assurance maladie
vous serez appelés progressivement dans
les semaines à venir aucun rendez-vous
puisse vous être proposés si vous le
souhaitez ce sont plus de 3000 personnes
qui vont être mobilisés à l'assurance
maladie pour le faire je veux dire aussi
un mot de l'avenir proche
ce qui se profile c'est une montée en
puissance continue de la vaccination
tout simplement parce que la production
mondiale de vaccins augmente et que donc
les livraisons de vaccins
la france augmente d'ici la mi-avril
c'est à dire d'ici trois semaines nous
aurons vacciner plus de 10 millions de
personnes soit une majorité des
personnes les plus vulnérables face au
virus les approvisionnements pour
augmenter je le disais et de nouveaux
vaccins vont arriver comme le vaccin
jones johnson & johnson johnson &
johnson à la mi avril
nous tiendrons les objectifs fixés avec
en ligne de mire
l'espoir immense du retour à la normale
ce que nous menons c'est une immense
campagne avec méthode avec détermination
nous déployons nos armes les vaccins
partout sur le territoire
des dizaines de milliers de
professionnels de santé d'agents de
l'état et des collectivités de sapeurs
pompiers de militaires consacrent leur
quotidien et toute leur énergie à vous
protéger
nous leur devons beaucoup je leur dois
beaucoup qu'il soit remercié
je veux tirer un coup de chapeau
particulier aux infirmières et
infirmiers de notre pays qui jouent un
rôle majeur dans notre système de santé
en règle générale et dans la réussite de
la vaccination en particulier leur
mission va encore s'amplifier dès demain
avec la possibilité qui leur est
désormais ouverte par la haute autorité
de santé de prescrire eux mêmes le
vaccin ce qui va leur permettre
notamment d'aller dans les populations
les plus vulnérables et de vacciner au
domicile des français tous ont répondu à
l'appel pour vous protéger je le redis
nous leur devons beaucoup qu'ils soient
remerciés
j'appelle aussi tous les étudiants en
santé et tous les professionnels de
santé jeune retraité a prêté main forte
pour la vaccination et dans les hôpitaux
quand ils le peuvent comme ils l'ont
déjà fait depuis un an nous avons besoin
de bras nous avons besoin d'énergie nous
avons besoin de tout le monde
il est trop tôt mesdames et messieurs
pour relâcher nos efforts et il est trop
tard pour abandonner
il faut nous accrocher rester concentré
sur l'objectif nous allons le faire nous
allons y arriver
je vous remercie
bon sang le jeune ministre valérie le
rouge france télévisions deux petites
questions est ce que vous pensez avoir
assez de vaccinateurs pour pour remplir
ses objectifs vous semblez faire appel
aux étudiants et aux retraités et par
ailleurs est-ce que vous étudiez la
proposition de valérie pécresse
d'avancer les vacances scolaires pour
faire face à la recrudescence des cas
dans les établissements scolaires sur
votre première question
j'ai saisi la haute autorité de santé
sur qui est habilité à vacciner qui est
habilité à prescrire le vaccin dont je
vous ai annoncé que les infirmiers
pourrait prescrire le vaccin c'est une
bonne nouvelle et qui est habilité à
réaliser une injection
j'ai déjà pris un décret qui permet par
exemple aux pompiers de faire des
injections intramusculaires de vaccins
et la haute autorité de santé a élargi
la liste des personnes qui peuvent
potentiellement injecter un vaccin avec
250 mille personnes de plus avec par
exemple les dentistes je ne pas vous
dire de bêtises mais je crois les
vétérinaires aussi pourraient être
mobilisés si besoin
nous avons des bras nous avons beaucoup
de soignants beaucoup de pompiers
beaucoup de personnes qui sont
mobilisables sur le territoire national
et je ne crois pas que ce soit un
élément bloquant je vous le redis
l'élément limitative de notre campagne
et cette limite est en train d'évoluer
dans le bon sens ce sont les livraisons
de vaccins qui nous sont faites plus de
91% des doses de vaccin weiser qui nous
sont livrés ont déjà été injectés
le reste c'est l'intervalle nécessaire
entre deux livraisons pour que les
centres puisse fonctionner donc on
vaccine vraiment à flux tendu vous posez
la question plus générale je m'y
attendais un peu de savoir s'il faudrait
ou non prendre des mesures
supplémentaires
je vous ai dit vraiment le point central
c'est que d'abord il nous faut pouvoir
vérifier l'efficacité des mesures qui
ont été décidées et appliquez là où
elles ont été appliquées
la semaine dernière c'est trop tôt pour
pouvoir juger souvenez-vous le
couvre-feu quand nous l'avions mis en
place
beaucoup disaient ça fonctionnera pas
que bout de dix jours on a constaté que
saab et c'est le confinement d'octobre
novembre
beaucoup disaient c'est un confinement
like vous ne fermez pas les écoles ça ne
fonctionnera pas et au bout de dix jours
l'épidémie a fortement baissé donc
permettez moi d'avoir confiance dans la
capacité aussi de réaction collective
dans ce moment de reprise épidémie
des français pour pouvoir adopter les
bons gestes et faire refluer les russes
si vous me posez la question de savoir
si il est impossible d'envisager prendre
d'autres mesures
je vous répondrais non si la situation
devait s'aggraver malgré les mesures qui
sont en place
si les hôpitaux devait déborder si nous
ne voyons pas si nous devions ne pas
voir d'amélioration sur le plan
épidémique
alors évidemment nous serions amenés à
nous poser la question de savoir s'il
faut aller plus loin et comment aller
plus loin avec quel type de mesures bon
ça on inclut zèle pour lmc également
deux questions d'abord sur le profil des
malades en réanimation vous expliquer
que les profits sont maintenant un peu
plus jeunes parfois sans comme en
mobilité est ce qu'il ya des
explications
peut-être clinique jeu pour expliquer
ces cas plus jeune est donc grave
est ce qu'il ya des éléments voilà de
commun entre ces cas plus jeunes l'autre
question concerne les déplacements
internationaux pour l'instant on peut se
rendre en europe notamment juste avec un
test pcr et pour les départements qui
sont sous conditions strictes
on ne peut pas aller à plus de dix
kilomètres de chez soi est-ce que là
cette question a été discutée en conseil
de défense et ce qu'avait dit gérald
darmanin sur notre antenne
hier alors deux questions très
différentes sur le profil de d'adultes
plus jeunes que les réanimateurs
soignant les services de ré armes
c'est je le disais c'est vraiment de
paramètres 1 il ya moins de personnes
très âgées en réanimation parce qu'elles
sont vaccinés ça c'est la bonne nouvelle
d'ailleurs pour l'instant on ne voit pas
le niveau de mortalité attendue par
rapport à la gravité de l'épidémie
parce que dans les ehpad nous avons
protéger les personnes les plus âgées
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça et ça valide le
choix que nous avons fait de prioriser
avant tout les personnes les plus âgées
celles qui allaient en réanimation
autrefois qui aujourd'hui sont protégés
par la vaccination
donc ça rajeunit mécaniquement un peu
l'âge moyen des patients en réanimation
mais par ailleurs et indépendamment de
cela oui il ya davantage de patients
plus jeunes en réa et ça c'est ce qui
avait été déjà observée en angleterre
lorsque le variant a été identifiée à
savoir une dangerosité intrinsèque aux
variants britannique plus importante et
qui peut toucher des adultes
plus jeune sur la question des mobilités
en général il y à une coordination
européenne notamment à l'égard des
travailleurs frontaliers vous le savez
chaque pays et ensuite évidemment
souverain au sein de l'union européenne
pour poser des conditions
supplémentaires l'allemagne a placé la
france en territoire de vigilance
renforcée enfin leur équivalent de
vigilance renforcée et avec les mambos
secrétaire d'état chargé des relations d
affaires européennes nous travaillons au
lien avec les différents ministres
européens de la santé mais des affaires
européennes pour pouvoir établir des
règles est plus claire possible pour le
ressortissant notamment bonjour monsieur
le ministre bastien g pour tf1 lci deux
petites questions également d'abord vous
avez parlé le protocole renforcé pour
les écoles est ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire un petit peu plus c'est ce que
par exemple fermer les cantines ou
envisager des demies jauge dans les
collèges sont des options étudiées puis
quand connaîtra-t-on ces protocoles
renforcée et une autre question sur la
vaccination est ce qu'il est possible de
savoir quelle est la consigne quel est
le protocole pour les doses de vaccins
qui reste en fin de journée qui sont pas
attribués ce que il ya envisager par
exemple d'appeler des personnes
éligibles même plus largement pour
pouvoir attribuer ces doses merci sur la
question du protocole
alors il existe un protocole sanitaire
dans les écoles ça chacun l'a appréhendé
quand on a des enfants à l'école voit
bien que la vie dans l'école a changé on
a fortement limité les brassages elle
port du masque il ya des règles qui sont
très claires ce que je vais vous dire
c'est que avec jean michel blanquer et
l'ensemble du gouvernement nous ne
souhaitons pas fermer les écoles et
comme nous constatons qu'il y à des
contaminations dans le cadre des écoles
et bien nous renforçons les règles
sanitaires à mesure que cela s'avère
nécessaire c'est un travail qui a été
engagé qui va mobiliser la communauté
éducative et le ministre concerné au
premier chef sur ce quoi faire des
vaccins en fin de journée déjà je vais
vous dire une réponse très simple ne pas
les jeter
mais je vais vous dire aussi une chose
je ne crois pas que nulle part en france
qui que ce soit jette des vaccins parce
que vous n'aurez pas trouvé pardon pour
l'expression clients pour utiliser les
dernières doses donc en général les
centres disposent de listes d'attentes
de listes d'appels et préviennent les
personnes en fin de journée y compris
d'ailleurs s'ils sont un peu en dehors
du cadre et ne jamais jeter de doses
évidemment c'est la règle de base
il est pas la peine d'écrire des
protocoles pour cela s'appelle du bon
sens
et quand on est soigneront n'en manque
pas bonjour et l'interview pour europe 1
tu m'apprends que j'ai deux questions la
première question concerne le
partenariat public privé que vous avez
évoqué tout à l'heure étant donné que
les services de réanimation sont sous
tension dans les hôpitaux dans plusieurs
zones notamment en ile-de-france est ce
que on peut encore concrètement pousser
les murs dans les cliniques
il ouvrirait délit et il transférait des
soignants et ma deuxième question
concerne la campagne de vaccination on
l'a compris ça s'accélère
elle vient d'ouvrir au plus de 70 ans mi
avril ce seront les enseignants fin
avril les forces de l'ordre comment ça
va se poursuivre cette campagne de
vaccination et quel âge quelle tranche
d'âge sera concernée et quels profils
également merci
alors d'abord sur la mobilisation du
secteur privé des cliniques privées
lucratif et privé non lucratif lié à
nous étions à 22% du participation de
prise en charge des malades en
réanimation par le secteur privé
à titre de comparaison nous étions à 18%
au cours de la première vague
donc quand je vous disais que la
mobilisation est renforcée sachant que
le parc privé n'a pas autant de lits des
animations à la base du parc public 1
donc on peut pas comparer les deux on
pousse les murs partout
par exemple nous étions avec le prétend
la république à valenciennes en début de
semaine 40% des actes de chirurgie ont
été déprogrammés dans l'ensemble du
secteur privé là bas donc nous poussons
les murs partout il ya des protocoles
qui sont mis en commun entre public et
privé
c'est la mobilisation de tous le dire
personne ne reste sur le bord du chemin
vous avez posé ensuite une question avec
des réponses sur lesquels je voudrais
juste revenir
lahlimi avril mais avait il nous avons
l'engagement de vacciner d'avoir proposé
une injection de vaccin est réalisée
injection de vaccin à 10 millions de
français parmi les plus fragiles vous
l'avez dit aussi nous ouvrons la
vaccination aux plus de 70 ans
il est possible qu aux alentours de la
mi avril nous ayons d'ailleurs atteint
les objectifs de vaccination de cette
tranche d'âge et que nous puissions
ensuite aller au delà
vous avez dit mi avril on va vacciner
les enseignants et ensuite on va rester
et forces de l'ordre
les prix dans la république a dit que
les enseignants effectivement comme les
écoles sont restées ouvertes pourrait
bénéficier d'une vaccination alors il a
parlé de
fin avril en réalité il a vraiment il a
surtout dit lorsque les publics
vulnérables rond atteint un bon taux de
couverture je n'ai pas entendu mais je
peux me tromper qu'il y ait un plan et
des dates pour la vaccination de forces
de l'ordre ou d'autres catégories
socioprofessionnelles dans d'autres pays
cela n'est pas encore en tout cas établi
c'est en discussion
dernière question merci agence de presse
ap une deux questions si possible
première sur le taux de vaccination en
seine saint denis le taux est très bas
la population à ces jeunes il ya des
professionnels de santé qui demandent
que la tranche d'âge soit plus jeunes
pour ces régions en urgence est ce que
vous allez considérer est une mesure
comme ça localisé pour ces raisons les
gens comme ça et deuxièmement on est
quand même dans une situation où plus de
200 personnes meurent tous les jours en
france
le monde a dit aujourd'hui que c'est
l'équivalent d'un crash d'avion tous les
jours qu'est ce que vous diriez aux
familles de ces gens des milliers de
gens qui sont morts cette année beaucoup
considèrent que ces man aurait pu être
évité par un confinement plus strictes
plus précoce contre le variant engrais
et ou avec une campagne à une politique
de vaccination européenne plus agressif
merci vous poser deux questions
importantes
la première question j'ai eu la réponse
tout à l'heure c'est le taux de
couverture de vaccination en seine saint
denis
c'était une question qui m'avait été
posées par monsieur stéphane troussel
qu'est le président du département de
seine-saint-denis et qui s'inquiétait du
ce titre de savoir si alors qu'on
affiche 50 % de vaccination des
personnes âgées dans ce département où
on sait qu'il ya des inégalités sociales
plus importante qu'ailleurs
c'était vraiment la population issue de
seine-saint-denis qui avait été vacciné
ou si ça avait été une part importante
de parisiens qui seraient venues se
faire vacciner en seine-saint-denis tu
la réponse nous sommes à 40 % 49 % de la
population de seine saint denis qui
résident qui a bénéficié de la
vaccination il ya donc un écart d'un ou
deux pour cent ce qui répond à votre
première question et ensuite en seine
saint denis comme partout ailleurs ce
que nous voulons c'est aller chercher
toutes les personnes fragiles
vulnérables âgées
qui n'ont pas encore été vaccinés de
manière alors proposer la vaccination et
leur proposer des rendez vous pour se
protéger et se faire vacciner c'est la
priorité
imaginez que une dame de 85 ans n'ait
pas pu se faire vacciner dans son
département et que son fils âgé de 50
ans lui est un rendez vous parce que ils
auraient été des brouillards ou qu'il
aurait été il aurait appelé au bon
moment ça n'aurait pas de sens et je dis
ça notamment à l'égard de ou d'un maire
d'une ville française qui aurait annoncé
qu'il souhaitait désormais vacciner
toutes les personnes de 50 ans et plus
dans le département en question les
alpes-maritimes la moitié de la
population âgée vulnérable n'a pas
encore été vaccinés n'a pas encore été
vaccinés donc jeudi la réponse est non
nous vaccinons d'abord les publics
vulnérables et ensuite nous élargirons à
l'ensemble de la population
progressivement et vous m'avez posé
ensuite la question des 200 voire plus
décès par jour
bien sûr c'est un drame chaque décès est
un drame mais chaque admission en
réanimation est un drame et quand on
m'interroge parfois en me disant s'il y
avait cinquante mille idées l'animation
on ne serait pas obligé de confiner je
suis le premier à répondre que s'il y
avait cinquante mille patients en
réanimation
ce serait un drame national parce qu'il
y aurait des dizaines de milliers de
morts en plus et que ce qui doit nous
guider n'est pas la capacité à soigner
les gens en réanimation ce qui doit nous
guider c'est l'objectif impérieux de
sauver des vies et de protéger la
population
madame le virus tue partout dans le
monde
les taux de mortalité sont ont atteint
des taux exceptionnels depuis un an en
france en europe aux etats-unis au
brésil dans la quasi-totalité des pays
et je ne parle pas des pays qui ne
tiennent pas qu'ils n'ont pas un système
de veille sanitaire qui leur permettent
de tenir à acompte à jour véritablement
la surmortalité
c'est évidemment autant de drames est-ce
qu'ils sont évitables
lorsqu une pandémie se déclenche
lorsqu'un virus un ennemi inconnu
indivisible microscopique circulent de
personne en personne ce que nous pouvons
faire c'est lutter contre sa diffusion
ce que je veux vous dire c'est qu'un
confinement généralisée il a des
conséquences
quand vous fermez tout l'activité
économique ça a des conséquences à court
terme à moyen terme à long terme lorsque
vous fermez des écoles cela a des
conséquences sur les familles cela des
conséquences sur les enfants
c'est bien sûr une mesure qu'on peut
prendre
l'avons déjà fait et nous le referons si
c'est nécessaire mais nous le reverrons
que si c'est absolument indispensable
parce que toute décision a des
conséquences qui sont importantes et qui
doivent être mesurées il faut prendre
des sujets dans leur ensemble et par
ailleurs j'attire votre attention sur le
fait qu'un pays voisins amis à tenter
cette opération qui a consisté à dire on
va tous fermés pour empêcher de variants
de circuler c'est l'allemagne
c'est l'allemagne l'allemagne a tous
fermés pendant trois mois je ne dis pas
ça pour comparer la france avec un autre
pays je dis juste que certains ont
essayé cette stratégie que nous aurions
pu adopter
l'allemagne a tous fermés le 13 décembre
les écoles les commerces tous trois mois
de confinement plus tard ils commencent
à rouvrir doucement le variant apparaît
il suit sa course inéluctable en
l'occurrence et l'allemagne est obligé
de recommencer à refermer des choses
plus longtemps donc aucune stratégie n'a
fait montre de son efficacité parfaite
en revanche la réponse nous avons entre
nos mains nous avons entre nos mains
c'est la distanciation sociale le
respect des gestes barrières et
l'attention que nous portons les uns aux
autres
tout d'abord la mise en culture on sait
qu'il ya encore pas réserve bien sûr
mais vous êtes médecin on aurait besoin
d'avoir un tout petit peu plus
d'éléments sur l'oxygénothérapie
renforcée qui est annoncé par l'afe si
vous pouvez juste vous expliquer ce que
c'est c'est plus sympa en réanimation
quel est son état de santé deuxième
question qu'on a eu on a fait un
reportage hier dans un centre de
vaccination et on a pu se rendre compte
que des personnes âgées de moins de 55
ans même très jeunes parfois dans la
vingtaine avait reçu des doses de vaccin
astrazeneca est ce que vous trouvez une
journée très clairement la consigne
aujourd'hui est ce que la haute autorité
de santé avait recommandé aux 35
certains mais enfin maxime tout de même
au prince où es tu
vous les posez une question je la prends
alors je ne parlais pas de l'état de
santé de madame roselyne bachelot parce
qu'elle a le droit comme chacun d'entre
nous au respect du secret médical par
contre sur les encourage dans le combat
qui est le sien et je lui souhaite le
meilleur rétablissement possible ce qui
m'empêche pas de vous répondre sur
l'oxygénothérapie sans savoir d'ailleurs
de quel type d'oxygénothérapie elle même
bénéficié aujourd'hui vraiment vous
pouvez avoir lorsque vous avez des
difficultés respiratoires parce que vous
êtes encombré des besoins en oxygène
qu'on peut vous administrez par lunettes
avec un débit d'oxygène assez lent et
parfois lorsque vous avez des besoins
plus importants
on peut avoir de ce qu'on appelle le lot
petit flou c'est de l'oxygène à fort
débit qui permet de fluidifier de
faciliter la respiration
je vous confirme que le vaccin
astrazeneca ne peut pas être prescrits
et administrées à des personnes âgées de
moins de 55 ans puisque la
recommandation la haute autorité de
santé s'applique partout la vie sans
masquer le plus vite possible le plus
vite possible le plus vite possible
vous savez que je ne fais pas de
prévisions ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que nous sommes dans un troisième
vague
nous allons affronter collectivement on
va la vaincre cette vague épidémique
nous l'avons fait signer vous souvenez
vous l'année dernière il y avait une
vague qui était très forte
nous découvrions le virus nous étions
beaucoup moins armé qu'aujourd'hui nous
n'avions pas les vaccins nous n'avions
pas la même manière de soigner les
malades qu'aujourd'hui les hôpitaux
n'avaient pas le même niveau de
préparation nous avons quand même vaincu
la vague donc nous allons vaincre cette
troisième vague en faisant tout pour
qu'elle soit la moins haute possible et
qu'elle fasse le moins de victimes
possible et ensuite progressivement nous
rouvrirons le pays des activités je
rappelle que certes la pandémie dure
depuis un an mais que pendant cinq mois
de mai à
octobre notre pays avait retrouvé une
vie beaucoup plus normal les restaurants
des fini par ouvrir les parts aussi les
théâtres les cinémas et ce dont nous
débattions et vous débattez sur les
plateaux de télévision c'était légitime
c'était faut-il aller au delà des 5000
personnes dans un stade où est-ce qu'il
faut se limiter à une jauge à 5000 donc
je veux dire aux français que au delà du
fait de les alerter sur la situation
sanitaire actuelle est de mobiliser
l'ensemble de la communauté soignante
évidemment qu'il faut donner des
perspectives ces perspectives ne sont
pas lointaine on n'est pas en train de
parler en termes de moi on est en train
de parler en termes de semaine et comme
la vaccination progresse qu'elle
progresse vite et que nous nous
protégeons de plus en plus et bien sauf
mauvaise surprise mais on n'est jamais à
l'abri d'une mauvaise surprise mais je
ne suis pas d'un naturel pessimiste
cet été pourrait être un était de retour
à la normale progressif et il n'y aurait
sans doute pas alors de deux vagues
supplémentaires à venir nous ne
désarmerons pas cet été notre vigilance
en tout cas du point de vue sanitaire
comme je lé fais là l'été dernier
j'étais allé en aussi des en dordogne en
mayenne que partout et caen-marseille
que partout où le virus se faisait ça et
là son apparition on ne désarmera pas
nous retrouvera une vie normale et je le
dis aux français il faut tenir quelques
semaines et on va y arriver
je ne qualifierais pas l'attitude ou la
décision du maire de cannes je regrette
qu'il ne l'ait fait de façon totalement
autonome sans tain alerté ni la
direction générale de la rs ni même le
préfet ni même l'ensemble des soignants
qui sont mobilisés pour vacciner à
cannes comme partout ailleurs en france
je dis juste que je suis certain qu'on
peut trouver à cannes
je suis certain parce que je le sais des
personnes qui sont âgés de 85 90 ans qui
n'ont pas encore été vaccinés comme
partout ailleurs en france d'ailleurs et
qui je pense ne comprendront pas
forcément que quelqu'un qui à 50 ans qui
est en très bonne santé puissent aller
avoir un rendez vous moi je préfère les
élus qui se battent pour aller chercher
chez eux s'il le faut par les personnes
les plus isolées et qui n'ont pas encore
pu être protégés parce que ce sont ces
personnes à qu'il faut protéger en
priorité
donc je le dis la vaccination des 50 ans
et plus sans comorbidités ne se fera pas
à cannes pas tant qu'elle n'aura pas été
décidé au niveau national pour toute la
population est donc pas tant que nous
n'aurons pas protéger la totalité des
personnes âgées fragiles
érable et enfin vous m'avez posé la
question des drive mais pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas je n'ai sky is
the limit parents pour l'horrible
anglicismes mais s'il ya des drive qui
s'organise avec des soignants qu'on a
des conditions de surveillance des
personnes pourquoi pas je sais pas si
c'est indispensable mais si ça peut être
utile oui merci à tous